un a quand même qui doutent de la
réussite de votre entreprise un parmi
lesquels françois hollande qui prédit
déjà un échec à cette alliance 1 ce
matin il a dit cela ne permettra pas la
victoire votre réaction
aucune je ne sais pas fait je veux dire
c'est un défi ni chaud ni froid c'est
peut-être l'expression je suis un
républicain jeu toujours membre du parti
socialiste je trouve alors une ipp je
vais vous dire une chose il ya quelques
jours je suis j'ai eu des propos
qui se voulait drôle après bernard
casoni avec cet âge
parlant je veux dire c'est que je vais
arrêter de faire des blagues vous avez
[Musique]
déjà dire que je réagissais c'était
votre confrère laurence ferrari qui a
utilisé une déclaration monsieur cazals
qui est extrêmement dur voire même
méprisant vis-à-vis des gens comme moi
je suis attaché à la république à la
laïcité et je trouve qu'on ne joue pas
avec ces thèmes et me voir traiter de
quelqu'un qui méprisent ray la
république laïcité j'ai trouvé ça un peu
dur donc j'ai répondu en disant
puisqu'on était le jour l'orgie parlante
que le départ monsieur cazals etc etc
depuis j'ai tiré la conclusion assez
françois hollande que franchement j'ai
pas envie de passer mon temps à
commenter voilà je trouvais même jeu
mais après jésus christ que même s'ils
le pensent ils pourraient faire silence
et ne pas gêner ceux qui dans son parti
ont continué à défendre le parti
socialiste et cherche aujourd'hui après
en avoir discuté démocratiquement adopté
démocratiquement une orientation cherche
à mettre en place quelque chose des
gêneurs françois hollande oui c'est un
tireur dans le dos à l'heure actuelle
quelque on a l'impression qu'elle ne
propose rien d'autre que de passer son
temps à vouloir que nous faisons cela
dit landreau et de olivier faure
sont des gens qui n'ont pas faim vous
avez qu attendez vous l'exposition voyez
vous voulez je veux dire c'est qu'il est
en train alors que son parti a discuté à
adopter une orientation monsieur
hollande n'a rien d'autre à dire que ça
va échouer ça va échouer ça va échouer
en gros on a l'impression qu'ils ça fait
le jeu je ne sais pas si son objectif de
emmanuel macron
qu'ils gardent quand même sa carte au
parti socialiste c'est dans ça vous
dérange pas que vous l'accueille à bras
ouverts ya pas de croire bernard répété
moi j'ai pas entendu il garde sa carte
au parti socialiste dont parlait de
françois hollande mais je suis pas
il est vrai comme un dingue un bond
de josé bové daniel cohn-bendit par
exemple ancien député européen il estime
que cet accord est une escroquerie
dictée seulement par des tractations
électorale est ce que ça vous étonne est
ce que ça vous déçoit je vous en veux de
passer du temps là tu franchement
j'étais jeune homme est parce que je
trouve que c'est incroyable non mais je
vais vous dire une chose non mais c'est
pas des réactions
non ce n'est pas vrai je vais vous dire
et je crois que votre rôle ah mais ça ça
n'est pas de chercher qui n'est pas
d'accord parce que c'est parce qu'on
doit faire ce qu'on doit dire
je viens et j'accepte nuit m'attendais
je vous dis pas mais je peux aussi avoir
une opinion comme dirigeant politique
que de vous dire par exemple qu'à
l'heure où il ya 1500 candidats qui se
sont retirés en lalande cet accord qui
sur les réseaux sociaux on dit
généralement qu'il le faisait avec
enthousiasme que je vois bien que l'on
traque à quel endroit il ya un petit
problème et la voix discordantes jeudi
qu'au bout d'un moment c'est vouloir
faire croire qu'il y aurait une levée de
boucliers contre cet accord alors que
globalement la grande famille de la
gauche écologique est heureuse de cet
accord alors on a peut-être ici ou là
pour des raisons de françois hollande
qui peut être lille a subi un échec il a
du mal que ça réussisse vous connaissez
ça quand on échoue parfois on n'a pas
envie que les autres réussissent
échoué bernard cazeneuve a quitté le
parti socialiste stéphane le foll est
contre
finalement vous avez la peau du ps non
mais c'est pas ça l'objectif non je
crois qu'au contraire olivier faur marc
faire revivre le parti socialiste idéal
6h10 me jean luc mélenchon avait dit je
veux remplacer le ps eh bien c'est ça
non mais remplacé d'être la grande force
politique qui crée des conditions du
changement la ville va donc affaiblir
considérablement le paternalisme le
remplacer zone objets utilisés oui être
la grande force qui a occupé le parti
socialiste qui était celui qui était le
parti qui a changé la vie en 1981 nous
souhaitons jouer ce rôle là aussi mais
le fer avec dote la même façon que le
gardien sociale s mais pour le remplacer
à la même façon que le génie d'un homme
comme françois mitterrand quand il est
dans l'opposition c'est qui va faire va
passer de la et ses filles au lui va
prendre la direction du parti suisse et
crée des conditions de l'union de la
gauche dans des conditions encore plus
difficiles notamment en raison de ce
qu'était le parti communiste à l'époque
l'existence d'une ourse l'éthique tout
ce que vous voulez ce que je veux vous
racontez là à grands traits c'est que
notre tâche est de reprendre 7 h à la
salle
pas du tout la même histoire et pourquoi
c'est pas la même histoire parce que
c'est derrière le programme de jean luc
mélenchon et pourquoi vous dites ça et
la retraite à 60 ans
la planification c'est pas le programme
de fabien roussel c'est
dans une alliance à 4 le parti
socialiste qui n'est pas défavorable à
la retraite à 60 ans mais effectivement
dans le cas de deux c'est parce qu'il
n'ya pas que le parti chiite malgré
toute l'affection des gens mais que j'ai
pour ce parti d'accord c'est une
alliance et nous faisons ensemble un
parti quelque chose de programmatique et
enfin puisque on s'amuse à faire de
l'histoire tout de même quand on est
socialiste on est pour la retraite à 60
ans ça n'est pas contraire à l'histoire
du parti socialiste n'est pas contraire
à lille
dans les 110 propositions du candidat
mitterrand oui via la retraite a soif
ranquet l'année mais en quelle année
donc
et
déjà très critique fin avril disait ça
va coûter 70
on les a convaincus manifestons la force
de l'indus qui est sortie des urnes a
réussi à convaincre les derniers doutes
sur le fait que c'était possible et
nécessaire d'ailleurs parce que c'est ça
qui est important et j'ai répondu et
pardon parfois du style un peu un peu
vif à laquelle je vous réponds mais
fondamentalement là on est dans le vrai
sujet je ne sais pas si nous gagnerons
mois de juin mais je ne veux pas la
retraite à 65 65 ans d'évaluation je
veux la retraite à 60 ans parce que
c'est nécessaire parce que les chats
sont
déjà dans une situation de maladie
[Musique]